[Music]
so when we started creating DC Universe
Online we knew we were gonna have this
mentor system and they were gonna be
able to follow different heroes in
different villains who are gonna guide
them as they're this new hero coming on
the scene of the DC Comics what I love
about our game is that Batman and Oracle
they're talking to me they're not saying
another character's name they're saying
hey you you really helped us out today
that's why we want you to be a part of
our team try to deliver on the Batman
fantasy so you felt like you were Batman
or living in that Batman world you know
so you'll go to Gotham it's dark there's
all kinds of crime it things like that
only you can save them if you're playing
a whole detective role really when you
start out the game you're not dealing
with Batman himself except over a
communicator you're really dealing with
the supporting characters you're seeing
Robin you're seeing Harley Quinn right
off the bat you see scarecrows one of
the enemies that you're gonna encounter
so we show you scarecrow in there we
show the fear gasps and his little
minions and henchmen stuff and then you
actually go and you rescue fat woman so
you get to see another person with a bat
family along the way using the model is
actually pretty cool so this big swath
area looks really iconic cool-looking
stuff you got clowns everywhere you got
cops everywhere
players are battling each other at a
really really neat experience and then
you go into the funhouse
it's totally Joker dad you're totally
would you expect to see if you went into
Joker's hideout
Robin went in ahead and kind of got tied
up and you have to rescue him from
Harley Quinn we actually do a mission
where players just can't get rid of a
bomb and they're tasked to pick up one
of the Joker's bombs and find a place to
get rid of it and we end up throwing it
into the river as an homage to Batman 66
it's not till like halfway through the
game where you actually finally come
face-to-face with Batman as a player and
it's very cool because you get to
experience this fight from the hero side
and the villain side you fight alongside
Batman at the Regal Hotel against Joker
himself he's got bombs rigged up to gas
the whole place they're having a Gotham
City police department ball there
they're really pretty epic chaotic fight
that's a lot of fun and you have to get
to help Batman out for the first time so
it's not just Batman it's the Joker as
well and this is the first time that
players are actually gonna get to
interact
and they're gonna get to either fight
alongside him or try and take him on you
know and all this culminates in the
bat-cave Brainiac has dug into the
systems of the Batcave and he's using it
against the world at this point the
stakes have been raised from Gotham to
the entire earth because Batman is so
paranoid and so driven to keep tabs on
things and to have this control over
everything and Brainiac uses that as an
Achilles heel and you're actually
battling your way through it and you're
learning things along the way that
things have gotten out of control for
Batman is your fight no match for
fighting Brainiac control bat drones and
be like that at the very end there
you're actually fighting brother I
he's got beans going everywhere and this
whole coordinated effort to stay alive
and take him out to really really tough
fight you have to get in there and root
out all Brainiac subroutines and restore
the Batcave which allows you of course
to be one of the few select people who
are allowed inside the Batcave one of my
most memorable Batman moments from the
comics is is actually when Bane comes on
the scene and he stirs up all of the
villains in Gotham City to try and break
Batman down make him tired make him
weary and Oracle even comes on the line
and says hey this is personal he once
broke
Batman's back and we're not gonna let
him do that to anybody again so you get
to face him down with Nightwing at your
side we have this interesting thing
going on in Arkham Asylum in the game as
well where you know something is
stirring up all of the villains that are
in Arkham and sending them out into the
city and this is causing all this chaos
poison ivy
Mr Freeze and scarecrow each one of them
has their own wing that they've taken
over and they're actually recruiting
more members to sit on an army and they
take over the old city the Barry and
Batman shows up and thanks you for your
help in and you basically save the day
and it's a it's a big long fun alert one
of my favorites one way or another the
different nuances that have picked up on
the character and the various stories
and the interactions have crept their
way into the various
and DC Universe Online when I look at it
I kind of know where those things came
from and it puts a smile on my face when
I think back on you know all the years
and years and years I've been able to
enjoy this character
you
[Music]
you